du fascisme vert ils sont très très
dangereux ils veulent jusqu'à séduire
ils sont absolument pas motivés par une
sorte de discours écolo mais
complètement fanatisé donc pour moi
c'est des dangers publics pour la
démocratie et pour l'écologie en plus
donc vraiment c'est une très bonne chose
Gilbert était le seul à dire non bah oui
moi comme d'habitude je trouve que c'est
une décision politique et ce mouvement
oui ne peut pas être non mais on peut
pas et en gros on peut pas leur imputer
l'ensemble des violences moi je suis non
mais laissez-moi finir je suis contre
toutes les violences mais là ce sont des
révoltés de la terre qui luttent contre
des lobbies
industriels et agricoles ce sont des
gens qui ont une vision de la terre qui
n'est pas celle de la majorité mais les
prix
on ne parle pas de leur idéologie on
parle de leur action
il y a quelqu'un là-dedans mais ils sont
pas responsables des violences
Gilles et essayer de retrouver ton
cerveau pendant ces vacances
ça fait une polémique aujourd'hui il y a
plein de gens qui sont d'accord avec moi
excusez-moi plein de gens on va pas
tenir tout le monde est d'accord avec
l'écologie mais le problème c'est que
les actions comme ça en fait c'est
contre-productif ça crée le rejet tout
le monde est d'accord tout le monde a
envie de sauver la planète c'est un
combat qui est voilà on veut tous vivre
on veut tous vivre dans de bonnes
conditions mais là clairement ça donne
envie de dire bah non moi je suis pas
écolo franchement je vois ça je suis pas
écolo tu vois pas ça c'est que surtout
cette association en fait c'est une
association de plein de collectif c'est
pas une association
écologiste etc de gauche d'extrême
gauche et Gong et donc ils sont dépassés
leurs messages et dépassé et il démarre
toujours de façon pacifique et là le 17
juin dernier déjà ça à nouveau dégénéré
sur la fameuse ligne de train Lyon-Turin
ça démarre toujours pacifiquement et ils
sont toujours dépassés par par les
extrêmes
malheureusement tu es toujours du côté
de l'ultra-violence
bien sûr que si vous êtes
tu es toujours d'accord pour ceux qui
prônent la violence anti-fi que tu as
toujours identifié contre les
calumération
tu es tout ce que tout ce que tu es
contre tout ce qui peut faire respecter
la loi monter les gens signifie et ben
tous les soutiens quand on met les
camions de surveillance on va arrêter
les voleurs tu es con
ici c'est toi
j'ai jamais milité pour la violence mais
arrête mais c'était plus de position
Cyril
[Rires]
même la pause Valérie oui quand il y a
les débordements oui Cyril quand il y a
des débordements
du fait de casseurs on veut pas
dissoudre les syndicats mais non mais
alors pourquoi là
on voit très bien
[Rires]
c'est que par exemple dans les manifs
justement sur les retraites et cetera on
voit très bien qui sont ceux qui font
les débordements et qui sont ceux qui
manifestent pacifiquement là dans dans
cette association dans ce collectif on
ne sait pas qui est qui et c'est bien là
le problème c'est que justement il joue
sur cette ambiguë pour ça qu'il va avoir
l'ambiguïté pardon
c'est pour protéger les syndicats qu'on
vous dissous des Black Blocs et c'est
pour protéger ceux qui sont vraiment
besoin et le le ressenti de protéger
l'environnement qu'on veut dissoudre des
casseurs si profite de ces
manifestations
qui sont de ton mari tu dis que tu n'es
pas le seul qui sait ce sont tes amis
et Sandrine Rousseau
ridiculiser lors de cette avant-dernière
où il y en avait qui envoyer carrément
des grenades sur des policiers sur des
capteurs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il est et les 12 policiers blessés tu en
as rien à c'est-à-dire que quand
il y a un black bloc qui se casse un
doigt tu fais tu cries au scandale et là
les 12 policiers on s'en fout là
[Rires]
mais en fait c'est surtout que tu pars
du principe que la dissolution est
politique mais ces groupes ces groupes
là sont des groupes ultra politisés
c'est des groupes de gauche et des
couleurs
des solutions justement c'est fait comme
dit Valérie pour pouvoir voir qui est
qui est enlevé le bon grain de leur fait
mais c'est vrai non mais c'est la vérité
Gilles tu es pas la moitié d'un con
franchement
c'est pas parce que l'écologie est un
sujet noble que ça doit autoriser toutes
les violences et c'est n'importe quoi et
là je pense même qu'ils se servent de ça
comme prétexte pour être ultraviolent en
disant non nous on est écolo et on peut
faire ce qu'on veut non je suis désolé
tout ce qu'ils veulent c'est défoncer
tout faire des incidents faire des
manifs et cetera donc c'est n'importe
quoi ils font du temps à l'écologie
qui veut défoncer qui l'a mieux défoncé
là merci Daniel non mais eh est-ce que
tu es comme Elisabeth Band qui n'a pas
le courage de parler d'écotérisme parce
que ça ce qu'ils font c'est de
l'écoterisme est-ce que tu assumes ça ou
pas
sainte Céline des gens qui laissent des
grenades sur des canettes
[Applaudissements]
le gros problème c'est qu'il vient de
t'appeler Cyril
quand tu es armé de bonnes ascension que
tu veux faire une bonne action tu te
mets pas en cagoule en cagoule comme ça
[Applaudissements]